I don't want to overstate the importance
of the growing Donald Trump battle with
Fox News because Trump and Fox News
getting along slightly less well as I've
been telling you that they're getting
along slightly less well it doesn't
really alter that in the big picture
when you zoom out Fox
carries water for Trump most hosts still
worship the guys every word you've got
Hannity Tucker Jeanine Pirro whatever
Trump might even see the increasing
battle that he has with Fox News really
only Shepard Smith and sometimes chris
wallace and some of the weekend hosts
trump might even see it as sport and a
way to get publicity by attacking fox
but the reality is that we don't want to
overstate the importance of that
conflict between Trump and some elements
of Fox News because overall they're
still on the same page and Fox is mostly
a pro Trump propaganda outlet but the
disagreements between Fox and Trump have
now spread beyond just Shepard Smith and
occasionally chris wallace and once I
believe Neil Cavuto even now Brett Bayer
is having reporter John Roberts simply
say Donald Trump's bogus sharpie altered
map of Hurricane Dorian is merely that
it's bogus it was never part of the
original forecast now I already told you
in the last story exactly how this map
was presented Donald Trump previously
saying Hurricane Dorian was on track to
hit Alabama
it wasn't Trump then tried to retro
actively defend that claim by using a
Sharpie not saying he personally did it
but someone did to make it look as
though Alabama was within the reasonable
cone or trajectory of that hurricane Fox
News then reported on this and they
didn't fall for it they said this was a
bogus altered map take a look
John you were in the Oval Office today
for that pool spray this afternoon the
president displaying a hurricane
forecast map but there appeared to be a
change made to it what what happened
this was following a briefing from Kevin
Mack alene and the Acting Secretary of
Homeland Security in as well to comment
out of the Coast Guard this is a
forecast track that the president held
up for
last week where it looked like the
hurricane was going to slam into the
Florida coast maybe even crossed the
potential and get into the Gulf of
Mexico you can see somebody with a
sharpie or some other writing instrument
added a little bit to the code of
uncertainty which was not part of the
official forecast which included the
Florida Panhandle in parts of Alabama
President Trump had tweeted over the
weekend that Alabama appeared to be in
the crosshairs and you could probably
extrapolate that if ahead of continued
on that track Alabama might have been
affected but it was never part of the
official forecast when asked this
afternoon how that marking got on the
map the president said he had no idea
right okay John Roberts live in the
North Lawn John thank you this is
hilarious but I really want to make an
effort to provide the right context for
these stories okay when it comes to this
Fox versus Trump thing let me zoom out a
little bit Fox News and even corporate
media more broadly are what we call
sense making tools and they are terrible
sense making tools for society so when
we talk about sense making and media
this is maybe one of the most important
analyses that we can do and I get it
we started with a sharpie but again I'm
making an effort to really provide
broader and important context through
when we do these media analyses stories
when we talk about the sense making
analysis for media it goes well beyond
the propaganda value of media we've
talked a lot about the propaganda value
of media and how media can sort of serve
corporate interests or political
interest for one party or another party
and you really have to zoom out to
understand this we are an estimated on
this planet we are an estimated seven
point seven billion people each kind of
existing in our little corner of it only
having an awareness of a tiny tiny
fraction each day of what happens on our
planet a nearly infinite I know that
that's not a precise term nearly
infinite but I think people know what I
mean a nearly infinite number of things
takes place every day depending on how
you measure them births deaths violence
storms crimes entrepreneurship food
growing medicine technology right I mean
it's like the list doesn't do it justice
because think about everything that goes
on in our planet
one day sense-making is giving meaning
to what goes on in our world so that we
can understand it because again so much
happens every day that the mind cannot
actually comprehend it so sense-making
is giving meaning to things that are
going on and this is actually what
corporate media serves on a plate for us
we can't possibly follow every
development that takes place on our
planet
so what media does is not only do they
explain things to us but they also
narrow the scope of what we pay
attention to and by virtue of that they
assign meaning to what areas of life
should we be paying attention to local
news your 11:00 p.m. local news takes
everything that happened in the day and
it makes sense of the world by picking
you know it's usually like five stories
one or two are usually about some
horrible crime that took place they give
you the weather and then a couple of
other stories and that's how they make
sense of the day for you and as I've
talked about countless times about
corporate media there is really no one
media outlet including me I mean I'm
including myself in this there is no one
media outlet that can really do sense
making justice because there's just too
much that happens in the world so to be
an informed person I've talked about the
knowledge pyramid before oftentimes when
I go in I talk to at colleges and
universities about critical thinking and
epistemology the knowledge pyramid is
this thing that you have to build up and
the bottom of the pyramid is critical
thinking skills
epistemology skills learning how to
think learning how to learn you then
build the pyramid further by taking
those epistemological skills and you
want to gain subject matter knowledge
about sociology culture physics math
whatever right you get subject matter
knowledge and then at the very top of
the pyramid is sort of like what happens
day to day you have to use that entire
base of the pyramid to interpret a
specific event to solve a specific math
problem for example when you think about
knowledge this way fox news calling
trump out or not calling trump out
really doesn't make a big difference in
terms of fox's bigger picture sense
making capacity
but when we think of the universe in
which your average trumpets is operating
people who don't have the epistemology
and critical thinking foundation people
who have not used that foundation
because they don't have it to gain
subject matter knowledge for them their
pyramid is truncated and in those cases
it actually can make a difference that
Fox News is saying the Sharpie image was
completely bogus it could pierce
someone's echo chamber it could get
someone to rethink their sense making
choices and it is still a good thing
that is a lot of context but this is I
think how we need to be thinking about
this very public sort of pseudo battle
between Donald Trump and Fox News and
Fox News occasionally saying what you
are saying there isn't true what Donald
Trump said simply doesn't correspond to
the facts and I think that if we want to
be informed news consumers and really be
thinking about these things more broadly
it's fun to watch Shep Smith say Trump's
a liar but we want to actually
understand the context and in the
context for an audience that is so
lacking that critical thinking pyramid
and the subject matter knowledge it
could actually get them to say you know
what maybe this guy is a liar and I
shouldn't support him in 2020 and to
that extent I think it's great let's
just not pretend that Fox News is not
still 95 percent carrying water for
Donald Trump and effectively functioning
as state media